only on CBS this morning the parents of
a young British man killed in a traffic
accident caused by an American woman
explained why they felt ambushed during
their meeting with President Trump at
the White House Charlotte Charles and
Tim Dunn met the president yesterday at
the White House and they discussed
justice for their son but declined to
meet with an sakulos who's waiting in a
nearby room she's reportedly the wife of
an American intelligence officer we
spoke to Don's parents this morning in
their first TV us TV interview since
that White House meeting
welcome Charlotte and Tim it's good to
have you back up first I want you to
tell us how did this meeting come about
did they reach out to you did you reach
out to them give us the details we were
in the process of doing another
interview in New York and a spokesperson
rat Seeger had a phone call from the
White House extending an invitation for
us to get there as soon as possible to
meet with whom a senior official that's
all we knew we had no idea who it was
certainly didn't think for a second it
would be President did did they tell you
that ends the coolest would be in the
White House so that came as a complete
shock so you walk into the rooms you're
shocked to see the president there and
then shocked to learn that answer coulis
is in the next room yeah he said she was
in the building but the room next to us
was not highly so what was said at the
meeting you walk in and he says what you
say why he offered his condolences
he seemed warm and he was welcoming
which was which was nice but it didn't
take long for him to then drop into the
conversation there and securest was in
the building oh no how did you feel when
he said that you know Tim well honestly
we just had discussed it on the train
going to Washington that we thought it's
full of scenarios that might have
happened and we did discuss it might be
the president and we did discuss that
maybe and would be there so we were sort
of it's pretty thinking it but it was
still quite a you know took your breath
away when he mentioned it first time
well clearly you were bother tell us why
you were bothered you said wrong set
what did you know wrong setting you know
we've said all along that you know we
are willing to meet her
we are still willing to meet her but it
needs to be on UK soil you know and with
therapists and mediators and that's not
just for us that's for her as well
you know she's traumatized her children
are traumatized you know to be thrown
into a room together with no prior
warning that's not good for her mental
health it's certainly not good for ours
we've got locked in grief for seven
weeks and you know none of us know how
we were going to react pressure on us
did you feel pressure Jim meeting he did
he did ask two or three times you know
he didn't mention it in there two or
three times because we said no we didn't
think it was right but he said again
didn't he know she's in that she's here
so let's get it on I guess I'm healing
there's something like that yeah yeah
you've mentioned to heal it so it would
have been a pressure but we stuck to our
guns we feel you know Charlotte you
grabbed him by the hand and and What did
he say when you talk to him and I wasn't
holding I didn't have his hand when I
was talking to him but I just explained
to him like I have done since we arrived
in New York you know if it was his child
he would be doing exactly the same as
what we're doing it's not right what did
he say when you said that you're great
he absolutely agreed he he was very
willing to listen
he sat didn't didn't interrupt me at all
I was just explained that you know it's
just not right I had questions who
allowed her to return to the u.s. did
you get an answer to their know him
Charlie I'm struck by both you and Tim
always seemed to show compassion and
cyclists you're saying this is difficult
for her and it's been a reported that
she's devastated by it she too was
invited to the White House she knew you
all would would be there and she was
hoping there would be a meeting but this
is not how she wanted it to go either
she okay I think she was hoping that you
would want to meet with her as well
were there cameras there you guys to
take pictures did you feel that this was
that there this would have been a photo
event oh yeah well we didn't have our
picture taken with the president
No how did you feel about the presence
of the cameras a bit strange I mean you
know we we couldn't slide in the
situation like that certainly wouldn't
have been a warming photographed for
them to have taken but I think and also
we we were shown out of a side entrance
away from all of the American most of
the American press because I guess they
didn't get what they were hoping us to
agree to so so what's what's next for
you two at this point we just keep
fighting justice we spokesperson is
speaking to lawyers we've already
instructed lawyers what does justice
look like ultimately for you ultimately
obviously we need her to come back to
that steel armor it's still our main
game it may not you know she games the
wrong word it's that still I mean aim
you know she needs to come back and you
wanted to come back why exactly because
I'm sure she's listening to you she
needs to come back and face the justice
system you know she needs to she needs
to do this for herself she needs to do
this for us she needs to do this for her
children set a good example to her
children
you know she's held her hands up again
in a statement to sweep saying that it
was entirely her fault she made a
mistake so stand up to your mistakes
take ownership of them all right
Charlotte Charles and Tim Dunn we thank
you again sorry
and we should note that answer Kula says
lawyer told CBS News at an cyclists was
invited to the White House but she
wasn't aware of the circumstances of
that meeting and the family seemed
really relieved to hear that to know
this she wasn't behind that kind of what
they're using the word ambush yeah
they're relieved to know that she wasn't
behind out there every step they keep
showing compassion you know towards
answer code did say this meeting felt
sort of surreal yeah II didn't know what
to think
a spokesperson for Boris Johnson says
that he supports the prime minister in
the UK supports the family's decision
not to meet with cyclists on the on the
terms yesterday
[Music]